simple rule of thumb if you like to to  make sure you tick off would be the  three hours so first of all we want to  rehydrate so we've exercised we've  sweated we've lost fluid with lost  electrolytes so rehydration replacing  what we've lost is the first it's the  first thing secondly is to refuel the  hardy of exercise the harder you  exercised the more carbohydrate you're  gonna burn through so we need to in the  hours after certainly before we we start  exercising again is to replace that that  carbohydrate so refuel and then it's to  recover and to repair and to achieve  that we need you know a certain amount  of protein  ideally taken as soon after the exercise  as possible is to kick start that  process so we're looking at typically  looking at about 20 grams of protein in  that period after the the exercise  session